now as for the vaccine cbs is now
helping vaccinate those in long-term
care facilities
and nevada is one of just the first 12
states to participate
eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough explains
monday cvs health announced the launch
of its covet 19
vaccination program for more than 40 000
long-term care facilities in nevada
the hope is to vaccinate more than 22
000 patients
nevada one of 12 states in this first
round it really came down to the state
themselves when they opted in to be able
to get the vaccination
and what vaccination they chose as well
so nevada chose spicer
and pfizer was approved as everyone i
think knows
prior to the journey it's a two-dose
approach with shots three weeks apart
the hope is by mid-march the vaccine
will be available to the general public
the government footing the bill so it
should be free to everyone
the vaccination itself that's through
the government so they they're taking
care of all that as far as the
administration fee for any health care
worker providing it
our the patient's insurance company will
cover that if they do not have insurance
there's also a program to make sure it's
covered
madison kimbrough 8 news now